welcome to the program Israelis have
been voting for the fifth time in less
than four years as polls suggest an
uncertain outcome early figures indicate
turnout is the highest in 23 years a
crucial question is whether former prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu will stage a
comeback despite facing corruption
charges he'll need to Cobble together 61
seats with allies
to get them his likud parties turning to
the far right it's expected to seek a
coalition with anti-palestinian ultra
nationalist politician itema bengavir
whose party has gained momentum in
recent months netanyahu's main rival is
caretaker prime minister yair lapid but
his anti-netanyahu Coalition which
included a palestinian-israeli party for
the first time collapsed this year
forcing early elections we have it
Stephanie Decker standing by at Ya air
lepids party headquarters but first
let's go to Bernard Smith who's in with
the likud party headquarters Camp there
um Bernard how confident are they that
they can Cobble together a coalition and
and ultimately get over the line
foreign
Netanyahu will always tell you that he's
going to make it in the last four
elections he said on Election night he'd
won the election and it turned out he
didn't have the votes in the horse
trading that went on in the days after
the turnout though is looking good for
57.7 so far today across a whole of
Israel but not so good for the
palestinian-israeli communities about 23
turnout and it's the turnout in this
election that really matters that will
really make uh the difference most
Israelis will be hard-pressed to find
any Israeli who hasn't got an opinion on
whether they are for or against Benjamin
Netanyahu so there are no votes
switching going on what the parties are
searching for are people who haven't
voted previously likud netanyahu's party
reckons is between 150 to 300 000
potential voters who didn't vote last
time so all the campaigning in the last
couple of weeks has been about getting
the vote out and he hopes he's got
enough extra voters out to get him and
his Coalition Partners over aligned with
those 61 votes they need the problem has
been that the Arab party turnout is not
as much as it should be they're really
looking at needing 50 turnout amongst
their Community to give them enough
seats in Parliament to stop
netanyahu's advance
if they don't then it's Netanyahu with a
who with these religious zionists the
settler parties the far-right parties
will
possibly form a coalition and you'll see
for the first time in Israel's history
far-right lawmakers in government all
right well we will be across that with
you no doubt that is Bernard Smith
covering the liquid party headquarters
for us thank you very much let's bring
in Stephanie Decker now who is in Tel
Aviv and covering the Yash ateed party
headquarters Steph there's been a lot of
focus on Netanyahu what messages are
coming out of lapid and and his party
yes because these elections are really
seen as a litmus test it's the first
election an extremely long time that
Benjamin Netanyahu isn't the Prime
Minister who is the prime minister the
acting prime minister at the moment
now for looking at the numbers and we've
been watching the numbers come in in
terms of turnout in terms of what that
means for the parties it's actually been
quite interesting because this High
voter turnout particularly among Jewish
Israelis are not the palestinian-israeli
contingent is that you may see the
smaller parties that are key to Yer
lapid's Coalition
um perhaps not even make it into the
classic perhaps not even seeing these
are hypotheticals but this is all
possible at this point in time not even
seeing a Palestinian Israeli party in
Parliament at all but all these smaller
parties is what year lucky depends on
um to move forward so it's going to be
very interesting once we get those exit
polls in about two hours from now the
polls had always said that it was going
to be neck and neck but I think this
unexpected High voter turnout could
change the game we're going to have to
wait and see what it means for the
parties if Benjamin Netanyahu doesn't
get uh you know the victory if you will
over 61 CTP it doesn't manage to form
that government then Yara lepid would
stay on as an interim prime minister
until another round of Elections
um early next year so again everything
is up in the air but certainly at the
moment the numbers the high bro should
turn out meaning that there's a big
question mark whether the smaller
parties are going to be able to make
that threshold into Parliament because
those numbers have simply increased they
need more voters
up in the air is the perfect way to put
it Stephanie Decker live for us there in
Tel Aviv thank you